there it is
this week the topic has sort of the
heart of Chinese and East Asian history
the tongue and Song dynasties and I want
to say a little bit about each East
Asian history more broadly to start with
it is the great comparison and has
become ever more evidently so in recent
years it is so cut off from the
afro-eurasian landmass that it is very
difficult to to engross Chinese history
much less Korean Japanese or Vietnamese
history into some narrative that emerges
from the Middle East or Central Asia or
the Mediterranean or Europe in other
words almost everything that I've had
you look looking at so far has a their
connections that you can make and with
the exception of the Han Rome comparison
which as I said is kind of an artificial
one and not wildly convincing East Asia
has been sort of off the map but East
Asia is is remarkably different and yet
it's a difference that that curve
compels comparison as opposed to the
difference you have in the new world or
in pre-columbian America which we'll be
dealing with next week where very few
people have tried to to see great
comparisons with
after Eurasian you know a Cuban a or
Eastasia because the differences appear
to be incommensurable and because you
don't have literary sources that allow
you to flesh out important points so the
question is what do you do with the East
Asian history if you're if you're
writing world history the answer that we
had in writing the earth and his peoples
was to make sure that we had a really
good East Asian historian on our author
team
Pamela Crosley was a teachers at
Dartmouth as a distinguished professor
of East Asian history there but after
the third edition she decided to
separate from the group so while her
name is still on the cover because by
contract the publisher could use our
names forever you know long after our
demise you know our names can still show
up on the earth and his peoples she went
off and did other textbook projects and
so on and we were we benefited from the
fact that she had created a structure
for us that would carry on our coverage
of East Asia after she left the group
there's a question of who was going to
pick up East Asia and we talked
extensively about finding a new author
and one thing in another and then enough
I picked up East Asia so know my
responsibilities became expanded
but that also in a sense I think was
essential for moving from being a middle
east historian where comparisons with
you know ancient Near East with Rome
with Greece with Central Asia with India
with Africa are kind of natural
extensions to having to think more
concretely about the the different
qualities that you guessed that then you
get to when you a move into East Asia
both what the qualities are and why they
seem to be so different
obviously when you come to the new world
the why is easy to explain
there weren't any Europeans there but
for East Asia you have to be more little
more perspicacious my own introduction
to Chinese history ok many years ago
when I took a survey course with two
very famous professors at Harvard John
King Fairbank and Edwin old father
Reischauer a course called rice paddies
as a full year of East Asian history
Fairbank was a specialist in China rice
our the specialists on Japan and the
course proved to be memorable but
memorable for the wrong thing perhaps I
did decently in the course and it was
interesting and I memorized the roughly
the dates of the Chinese dynasties and I
learned something but it was an early
lecture by John Fairbank that somehow
became riveted in my memory this was in
the 50s when we did not have relations
with People's Republic of China and so
he was showing slides to to tell us
about what China was like visually old
two inch black and white lantern slides
and he showed a picture of a group of
villagers on the North China Plain which
is where of course Chinese civilization
is felt to arise and they were standing
on the outskirts of the fringes of a
conical pile of dark matter and he said
that human waste is collected as night
soil and used for fertilizer and then
the next picture showed several sub
cones the big one had been divided and
the same villagers are there and he said
when you have collected enough night
soil you can divide it into smaller
piles that that's it that is the big
memory of course and the reason it's a
memory is that I somehow had a epiphany
at that moment and I recognize that this
is the great metaphor of historian that
your your basic material the documents
the records the archives the the
material artifacts are nightsoil
but when you get enough but you can
divide it into smaller piles and the
skill of the historian is in the
division into the smaller piles that it
is the organization of the of the data
that for one reason or another has
survived from the past rather than the
data themselves that that you know makes
a construction of history persuasive or
not persuasive
and that of course was an epiphany I had
in the context of East Asian stuff East
Asian civilization and it's kind of led
to thinking about well is East Asia one
big pile or is it a series of smaller
piles and if it's the latter how do you
how do you divide them now the subtitle
of that course was East Asia the great
tradition which basically said it's one
big pile and there was a lot of
historiography of that period that was
really oriented toward that idea that's
basically you have the history of China
and then it has some outliers but it's
the central story of China that is the
history of East Asia and that central
story focuses on a series of dynasties
these dynasties are conceived of as
having the Mandate of Heaven Heaven
being in this case a kind of analog for
for the Almighty and Western traditions
and from save 6:50 down to you know the
beginning of the 20th century the
heartland of China that is say China
Manchuria Tibet you know China and it's
the areas that the Chinese government's
claim to be pure Chinese that area has
rarely been ruled by more than one
administrative entity at a time in other
words a single central government is the
dominant story and from about 1275
that's the last time you have two
governments from then on you really have
a series of of centralized states which
supports the one big pile thesis backing
this up was a very strong tendency at
that time back in the 50s and 60s to pay
a great deal of attention to
Confucianism and to the idea that there
is not simply a political center of
gravity that expresses itself in Chinese
history but even more a an ideological
center of gravity focusing on
Confucianism which through by means of
which you can see the extension of the
Chinese model to Korea Japan and mmm or
the old name for Vietnam that the
Confucian classics came to be read in
those in those areas there was always a
certain artificiality to this that is to
say the tendency was to to say
relatively little about Buddhism even
though Buddhism became in the post Han
centuries of division in China and well
into the Tong dynasty Buddhism became
the popular religion of China and spread
into these outlying areas so it became a
primary religious outlook for Japan and
Korea Vietnam but it did not have the
the unity that that existed in
Confucianism because whereas you had
certain classic Chinese works that we've
been translated from Sanskrit and that
were considered the Buddhist scriptures
there are a variety of them and
different different Buddhist
interpretations would call upon
different texts or interpret the text
differently as opposed to the Confucian
texts which were attended to have a
fairly consistent interpretation even
when you moved out of purely Chinese
territory so Buddhism was under under
stressed Taoism more of a nature
oriented non-governmental philosophy
tended to be under stressed and there
was very little ever mentioned about
local religious traditions in China even
though those traditions hour showed
enormous tenacity a few years ago there
was a book written on Fox demons in
China and it was fascinating for
hundreds hundreds of years there has
been the a belief widespread in China
that foxes can appear in human form as a
kind of demonic something maybe akin to
the gym for the Arabs or something of
that sort and the Foxes have the
capacity to bring you a business success
so you want to propitiate your Fox and
they are foxy they are sexually enticing
so you can find yourself married to a
Fox without I can't say without
realizing it could hey you must know and
you'll have shrines to the foxes where
you can
they'll make offerings and so forth and
propitiate them but they could also mess
you up so you have to be afraid of the
foxes this the the data in this book
brought the question of the veneration
or the belief in Fox demons basically
down to the present day it's been around
for a couple of thousand years but it
would never get mentioned in the sort of
the high culture assumptions that have
that have been so much dominant in the
narration of Chinese history and oddly
enough I after I read the book I talked
to a colleague who is a specialist in
Japanese history and said oh you know
the of the Imperial line of Japan
descends from a fox is that the same as
the Chinese and the answer was the
Chinese believe in foxes so here you
have two parts of this East Asian
civilization that are really into foxes
and they don't communicate on the matter
because there are so many things that
are below the the threshold of
historical visibility now one of the
things that happens when you have a
region like Europe in particular where
you have a an enormous fragmentation of
politics is that those things that are
local are likely to be talked about and
have some sort of significance imputed
to them whereas in areas that you where
you have a comprehensive state you're
perhaps less likely to have these local
isms President on the other hand the
local isms are all in the record
now this showed up historiographical II
in a couple of ways one was to to try to
diminish to sort of provincial eyes or
de-emphasize the history of the the
mainstream Chinese population the Han
Chinese and to talk about other people's
the hut the Han Chinese are vastly
preponderant demographically and they
are the people most associated with the
dynasties of the the song and the Ming
and the Ching and i'll about the chain
that are branches but but the idea that
that non Chinese peoples have had their
fates and their identities folded into
the history of the Han Chinese that
became a historical graphical
historiographical concern so a
destroying she said let us recover the
other Chinese not literally the Han
Chinese but the other people who were
playing a role in East Asia in some
cases that would be fairly obvious like
the Koreans in the Japanese or the
Vietnamese from in other cases are much
less obvious the role of the nomads from
the northwest whatever they were called
of the Mongols and the Manchus of more
directly to the north are the Tibetans
from the West and various people's from
the southwest which still remains a
comparatively understudied area at least
from the from the perspective of trying
to bring the southwest into the whole
the whole sweep of Chinese history that
was what Pamela Crosley brought to to
our text she was deeply interested in
the Mongols and in other non Chinese
players in the
in the broad story of Chinese history
less interested in those that have
established States the Koreans and the
Japanese the enemies but very interested
in the Central Asian and the northern
connections of that you had but also in
the Southwest connections for example by
emphasizing the the origin of the Black
Death
in southwest China the Black Death that
struck Europe in 1348 just recently it's
been reported
that the study of corpses from plague
pits in different parts of Europe have
confirmed that the black death was in
most parts of Europe a single organism
and that bad as an organism that does
come from Southwest China where it is
endemic among rodents in the area so so
Pamela Crossley gave us three chapters
that were you know that talked about
this diversity of the one for this week
and then the week after next we will
have a chapter on the Mongols and their
effect that was originally two chapters
but there was some sort of pushback from
people saying why do the Mongols get two
chapters and the Chinese don't get two
chapters or the Lithuanians don't get
two chapters or the Belgians don't get
to check why do the Mongols they killed
everybody
they were bloodthirsty they were they
were awful why do they get through
chapters so that had to be taken apart
and put back together in a single
chapter form which was my task but that
was one way of looking at and talk about
the the non Chinese people's involved in
it
the
the other way had more to do with the
question of of comparison where you you
say is this a civilization that has
qualities that could be compared with
other world regions that are not
necessarily derivative from some sort of
political or religious or philosophical
central story and so you had a the
growth of an increasing emphasis upon
Chinese East Asian history from a
material standpoint via the economy I
think probably the the first really
influential work here was a book by Mark
Eldon called the pattern of the Chinese
past came out of the 1970s more recently
we have had books comparing China's and
China and other parts of the world in
material terms such as ger Lloyd's the
ambitions of curiosity which compares
China in the ancient period with
greco-roman particularly with Greek
society and more recently Kenneth
Pomerance a book called the great
divergence that deals with with China in
comparison with Europe in the 18th 19th
centuries so what happens in these
efforts is that the longitudinal aspect
of Chinese history
this idea that you have a law a long
series of of single government political
structures that that invites you to sort
of move from dynasty to dynasty making
comparisons longitudinally as you go
forward become sort of taken apart and
you say well let's let's look at China
in this moment and that moment in
comparison of other places it doesn't
lessen
that you have a some kind of big pile
essence to East Asian history but it it
attacks it from a different direction if
you want to get a feel for the
difference that Chinese history has one
place to look is in a justifiably
ignored science fiction trilogy that's
considered to be the pioneering work in
Chinese science fiction that's by
I John she Guo and it's called the city
trilogy
it's about planets somewhere that have
various people's or you know races on
them that enter into different relations
and if you have read as I have no
virtually every big science fiction book
of the last 50 years and you go to this
you say wow this is this is different
this is really really really different
it's boring and it doesn't have much of
a takeaway in the long run but they
didn't but you think this must be
written by someone who's really Chinese
because you know it it assumes there is
this great story about the city of Sun
lawn and over thousands of years the
city persists and it is sacked it has
rebuilt its sacked and us rebuilt and on
and on and on to no particular point but
underlying it there is a philosophy and
the philosophy is embodied in a series
of monosyllabic terms that all sound the
same I like you know who coup Lu mu nu
se so he was an expert in cuckoo mu nu
and somebody else was actually more
adept in who knew Guddu and it it's
weird and but it's very suggestive
because it it leads you to thinking
about how the degree to which your own
assumptions about abstracting a
narrative of something are affected by
your by your cultural and historical
heritage I remember sitting down once
and writing an outline for a science
fiction novel a great inner
you know intergalactic interstellar saga
that was entirely based on the Crusades
and I thought it was really cool but not
worth writing it but it was very clear
that it was going to be based on the
Crusades you take a new work or
something
say by Neal Stephenson's novel Ana femme
a great novel of enormous length and you
realize about halfway through that it's
the story of Western civilization the
last several thousand years and the next
several thousand years all put together
in this artful science-fiction package
because in some ways the the imagining
that you have of the abstraction let us
say that leads into the imagining of a
future or a different Society arises out
of your own out of your own heritage
about the equipment that you have that
you have grown up with
so I inherited this job of handling East
Asia from the feedback of users they
said we want more on Korea we want more
on Japan we went more in Vietnam we
already have enough of the Mongols thank
you but we don't need so much on China
per se and I'm not sure that that is
going to persist I mean one of the
questions that we have a very beginning
of this course I said would it be
possible to write a world history for
all the world and it raised the question
as to whether the circumstances of the
world become a very broad determinant of
what is important in the world
so that as China or if China becomes a
spectacularly more important part of the
world will there will you have a
corresponding growth in the sense that
the story of China should be told get
more abundance will the number of
chapters devoted to China increase as
the Chinese GDP increases and I don't
know it's it's something of a mystery as
to what the feedback mechanisms are in
this sort of thing I think the in the
aftermath of 9/11 we have seen that
there are some very clear feedback
mechanisms at work in instructing us
what we should be looking at in history
so that we're now being told in the
aftermath of 9/11 that we should pay a
great deal more interest to the confit
evanthia the living together quality of
Jews Christians and Muslims in Spain in
the Islamic period even though there
might not have been that much difference
between Spain and Egypt everyone points
out that waimana T's was a great
philosopher from Spain but he also lived
in Egypt we're told now that we should
pay more attention to the Crusades for
better or worse or to the conflict
between the Greeks and the Persians or
to issues of Islamic religion that that
had virtually no interest whatsoever for
anybody prior to prior to 9/11
so what we've experienced is that a
world affecting event has put pressures
on historians to change the mix to to do
history a little bit differently well we
can do that because if you're in Western
history whether it's in the Islamic side
of another Christian of the Jewish side
or the Russian side or something like
that you know you can fake it you can
you know you can tweak it this way or
that way to suit an audience the
question is whether that will whether
that will hold for East Asian history
you know will we have a a felt need
either to glorify the Chinese past or
possibly to demonize the Chinese past or
both and we can't see that at the moment
I mean in a more grander context you
know if global climate change leads to
the world's chief you know farmland
being in Canada and you know northern
Russia then we may have to tweak things
another direction child this is the only
possible tweaking in the involved but
certainly the role of China is a is
something that is that is in play at the
moment now there are two other things I
want to point out in this and in this
respect and they're kind of opposites of
what another one is the question of the
story of contacts there is a school of
thought in world history writing that
moments or incidents of contact between
cultures
should be central stories in terms of
the the narrative of world history
central stories because they are small
acts that anticipate the convergence of
the world in an era of globalization in
other words if the big theme of world
history is that the globe eventually
comes together that the different
peoples get to know each other the
different cultures affect one another
different political and economic
structures sweep across the globe
if convergence is the the big theme then
do you do you give special attention to
those moments or individuals or events
that seemed to either contribute to or
signal this sort of thing so you have a
an emphasis on certain travelers or
merchants or artifacts that seemed to
betoken some sort of contact in other
words you can read a a book on Roman
commerce in the Indian Ocean and you'll
be told that Roman coins show up in
India maybe they show up in China as
well but you won't be told what the
local coins are in India you'll be told
whether there are Roman coins in India
and and you're you're led to think gee
if the Romans got there that must be
something if Alexander the greatest
considered the the parent of the royal
families of Malaysia then that must mean
something even if it's total nonsense
and yet alternative stories about where
the royal lineages of Malaysia came from
aren't aren't talked about because it's
the Western connection that seems to be
the important one because that's the
link how important are these links
my inclination is to say that these
links have been you know exaggerated and
that they don't necessarily have a great
deal of importance although they often
yield of very interesting stories but
that the the differences are more
intriguing let me give you a couple of
examples of differences when you study
the history of money it is there's a
standard narrative which you've picked
up bits of in previous chapters of the
earth honest people's standard narrative
in which quaint edge is invented in
Libya in the sixth century BC in in
Turkey that the practice of hammering
and image onto a piece of gold or silver
spreads from there and that coining
becomes very rapidly a commonplace
throughout the the so-called ancient
world and a great deal can be known
about it because the coins actually
survived and you can study the coins in
in many ways you can look at the images
on the coins and interpret them in
various ways you can read the
inscriptions on the coins which
sometimes are simply the name of ruler
but often they will tell you other
things you can look at the denominations
of the coinage
which may be there and you can look at
how the coinage of varies over over time
and numismatists have developed
extremely sophisticated ways of
analyzing kleynach you know there is a
summer seminar for graduate students in
the American Numismatic Society where
you can actually learn some of these
techniques and you realize that this is
a a major source of of historical
knowledge for anyone who's in Islamic
history there's the added advantage that
every coin of virtually at least after
700 or so has the date of the issue of
the coin written out in Arabic words and
then after about 1400 so in in numerals
and it has the place of the mint put on
the coin so you can actually see you
know the ebb and flow of this clinic and
the coinage is in gold and silver and
copper you get extensions of it into
India extensions of it into into a
Europe rather belatedly extensions some
extension of the south of the Sahara but
you get to East Asia and the coinage is
entirely different entirely different in
the first place
gold and silver are not used instead you
have copper and it's it's usually said
that copper is the coinage of China say
in the period of the Tong and the Sun
but but in fact you have other
traditions in China there are areas in
western China that use iron coinage
areas in southeastern China that used
lead coinage and some that use a
a combination of metals but the main
area region was well used copper not
only that but the copper was cast in
moulds now the the notion of making a
coin in the West was that you had a you
would something like a it was stump of
wood and then set in that there would be
a an iron die and this die would have
carved into it an image on the top then
you would take a this is called the
anvil die then you take another die and
that's called the hammer die and you put
the blank or the flan on top of the
animal die and you lower the hammer die
on top of it you take a hammer and you
smack the hammer die with the hammer and
this caused us in silver and copper and
gold are comparatively soft the image
that is on the the anvil die becomes
hammered into the one side of the coin
and that that is on the hammer die gets
on to the other side of the coin and so
then you have a finished coin you move
it aside and you put another blank in
there and you hammer another coin mm-hmm
the width of what of the coin of the
dies it's the same as the width of the
coin
yeah they're comparable II a small
that's the reason you have the animal
die is set in much larger base but it's
how big the coin is will be the
determinant of how substantial the die
is and this is a this is known as you
know stamping a coin that's what's done
is an event and it has certain technical
qualities for example the orientation of
the hammer die to the animal to the
anvil die you know
Kling catalog you might see an arrow I
will say they're pointed in the same
direction or they're pointed in opposite
directions or they're pointed crosswise
because in some cases they're hinged and
therefore you get a constant thing it's
also well established that the hammer
die wears out before the anvil die
because it's getting more of the force
from the hammer and therefore if you
have a crack that inevitably cracks
appear the crack appears first and the
hammer die and therefore you wear out
the hammer die before you wear out the
animal die so then you put in a new
hammer die and then you say okay well
here's a coin that has a anvil die and a
new hammer die and you you put hundreds
of coins in a row and you can say oh now
we have known as die links and therefore
we can give a chronological series by
the replacement of dies the very
sophisticated stuff but of course you
may have to hit hit it twice with a
hammer because you miss the first time
and then you get double struck coins or
all sorts of weirdnesses show up in this
in this process but if you know what's
going on
you can tell a lot at one point in my
career I got a call from the head of the
the chief Islamic numismatist of the
American Numismatic Society and he said
that a horde had been found and it had
gotten onto the coin market had been
found in Iran and half the hoard was in
London and the other half was in New
York and it would soon be dispersed
among coin collectors by the merchant
who had the hoard and he wanted to have
a hoard recorded before it got was first
but he didn't have time to do as he
asked me if I come to New York and
record the hoard and so I came down and
for the first time and only time I had a
stack of gold coins you know they're fun
to play with you know you can put in
your nose your ear you can just sort of
rub them throw them up and down all
those things you'll want to do with gold
but as I as I started recording the the
hoard it quickly became apparent that
all of the coins were from the same dyes
and I could lay them out in order at
which they were struck because there was
a crack and the crack grew and I could
see the crack grow over a sequence of
about 70 dinars here's a gold dinars and
and so then you think why would you ever
have 70 Goldie dinars that are
sequential issues from the same dies
particularly when they are from a ruler
who had previously been known to have
only two extant coins or two or three a
virtually unknown ruler from a
numismatic point of view and it suddenly
became obvious that this was this was a
payroll for an army that lost the battle
and the paymaster was killed and he had
buried the pay
and some farmer found it probably in a
pot somewhere in his field and took it
to an antique dealer who bought it for
you no no foolish on the Deena I mean
for not much money and and now it was
getting into into the trade and every
collector is going to be told this is
one of the rarest coins of the world
because coins by this ruler are
virtually unknown because nobody would
know that there was now a great mass of
these dinars out there so numismatics
becomes a very important historical
source for for Western historians and
does not become at in East Asia because
they they cast the coins they make a
mold
they put molten copper in the mold when
the mold is open the coins are you know
come out and they're they're coppers so
typically you take maybe a hundred or a
thousand copper coins put them in a bag
and tie up the bag and then seal the tie
so that you're actually paying things in
purses rather than an individual coins
because the value of the coin is low I
think well what difference that make
well want to think when differences is
that your money weighs a lot you know to
pay someone half a million dollars in
pennies you know more than one briefcase
is needed for this you can't do it in
your standard action movie so what
happened in the period of the Tang
Dynasty and earlier but continuing into
the Tong was that officials in northern
China were paid in silk silk so that
lengths of silk
would be part of their pay because silk
was fungible silk was a valuable item it
was it came in fixed lengths and
qualities and it was comparatively light
it was high-value and it could be
transported on me
on the Silk Road to buy goods from
Central Asia and from the Middle East
and Mediterranean world so one of the
results is one it's very clear in the
naming of the Silk Road that goes back
hundreds of years was that silk was not
simply a consumption commodity of the
Silk Road but was actually a means of
exchange so when you read stories of say
buddhist monasteries in central asia the
quantities of silk that they have are
just staggering because they'll be given
as as gifts by by the faithful things
like that but the the history of of
coinage in in East Asia becomes very
complex over time because if you tie up
huge amounts of copper in your money
then you have less copper available to
make implements then they're you know
what happens after the new world arises
and you have silver from the new world
showing up in China in this the
so-called Manila galleons across the
Pacific Ocean so there's a very
elaborate story of metal in East Asia
between China and Japan and Korea and
the Philippines and traders coming in
from from overseas but the types of of
things that you learn from coinage and
the West don't show up in the same way
it's it's it's a different
it's a different set of skills that you
bring to that sort of study a parallel
example is printing the in the tongue
and even more in the some era printing
through wood blocks becomes highly
developed in China the way it is done is
that you have a an author who with a
brush and ink you know writes a page and
then that page of writing is glued
upside down on a piece of wood then you
have a woodcutter who cuts around every
eight area and cuts out the area between
the inked areas so that so the inked
areas are the written areas are elevated
and the others are not then the the
paper is removed and replaced by ink and
then that is your woodblock that you
print with woodblock printing becomes
widespread and it includes books that
are devoted to practical arts we have
treatises on agriculture that are highly
detailed on manufacturing matter of fact
on a huge array of subjects and these
books are become the common possessions
of land holders and merchants and so on
so you have a printing culture that is
also a
book culture and it makes a great a
great deal of sense that that is how
things would be the Koreans develop it
into a into a movable type system and
devise a separate alphabet for for their
own language but basically it's it's
something that arises in China and Korea
roughly the same time and at roughly the
same time it appears in in Egypt and in
Iran in Egypt and Iran the you have a
print phenomenon but you have no books
it is it's a somewhat curious phenomenon
and one that was so little known that oh
say prior to the 1980s there were there
were like three publications that
mentioned that they had once had
printing in the Middle East and none of
those publications was read by by
anybody one was the for the earliest one
was a late 19th century catalog of a
papyrus exhibit in in Vienna written in
German nobody read that but it actually
had pictures of printed material from
from Egypt from medieval Egypt and then
there were one or two more mentions of
it and this is one of you know to blow
your own horn moments of the course of
which of course we've had many eye
asked our papper ologists here at
Columbia if he would sort of show me the
pepper the papyrus collection over in in
Butler library in the rare book room so
we went over there together and because
we had they have a lot of papyri
and they're about a hundred and fifty
specimens of papyrus and Arabic from the
early Islamic period not a syllable of
which I could read you know papyrus
handwriting in Arabic is very very
specialized skill to decipher it and
after we looked at a whole bunch of
these dismaying ly difficult texts
mostly fragments well we got to I think
it was a cigar box and sort of emptied
it out on the table and looked at bits
and pieces of papyrus that had not been
mounted on glass and one of them was not
papyrus it was a an amulet printed on
paper and I looked at I thought my god
that is a specimen of medieval Arabic
printing which I which up to that point
there is only one specimen known but
he's published in the United States and
and then shortly thereafter I was able
to identify a text from the 10th century
that actually described the context in
which these prints came into being they
were they were forgeries according to
this text that is to say you would have
a person who was selling to ignorant
people an amulet or talisman written by
a saintly individual you you know go to
the peasant you say oh you roll this up
put it in an amulet case around here and
a key will be protected from from demons
it is written by shape
you know fool and who saw cliff whatever
it is and of course it wasn't written at
all it was just printed that you know I
was turning out bunches of amulets and
selling them as if they were handwriting
they didn't look like handwriting but
nobody knew that you could have any
writing that wasn't handwriting and the
source specifically said these are sold
to illiterate because a literate person
would be suspicious the handed but it
was an amazing text because it had the
characters were about a millimeter high
and they're 111 lines of text of which I
was able to read about the first fifty
by finding Quranic passages that were
there and the style was that of
numismatic kufan which is a very very
particular style of writing in Arabic
and it also became apparent that that
these prints were not made exclusively
once I found other examples were not
made exclusively on wood but were cast
metal and so the process appears to have
been something from Mesopotamia probably
where people would take a tablet of clay
of course they'd had tablets of clay for
you know thousands of years and they
would you know write a met and write
something in the clay then they would
build up borders around the text and
pour molten tin over the whole thing
then when the tin cooled they take the
tin plate off and used that to print
from because the plate would have
reversed the letters than when they
printed it becomes it becomes correct
again and and I found a poetic reference
to two metal plates of of this sort and
so then there was the question of
the earliest prints in the Muslim world
are almost simultaneous with the
earliest prints in China and that that
was a puzzlement did was this a Chinese
technology that came West or is it
simultaneous invention the argument for
simultaneous invention was strengthened
by the fact that all of the known prints
which now we have in excess of a hundred
worldwide you know after I published on
this museum curators started to open
their amulet cases as who cared what was
in the amulet case is a nice amulet case
that was on exhibit they opened and they
started pulling out printed you know
medieval prints and then they found them
in actual excavations in Cairo so no
there's no question about it but the
common feature is that all of the prints
are on paper but paper was invented in
China and we have chronicles that tell
us that in you know in the six what 750
s there is a battle in Central Asia
between the Chinese and the Arabs and
that prisoners taken that battle in
where Chinese prisoners were taking the
Samer camp where they taught the Arabs
how to make paper so we have a plausible
a ballpark period for the beginning of
paper and then the printing comes after
that although actually the paper
techniques were rather different paper
techniques in China had to do with
chopping up the leaves whereas in the
West
the Middle East came chopping up cloth
so the paper probably comes from China
there's an excellent book by Jonathan
bloom called paper before print but the
printing appears and it has no impact
one print that has been found is a page
from a Quran only one page I've never
seen the original I don't know whether
it's printed on both sides or not I
think it's all the on one side but it
suggests that somebody actually printed
a Quran in Arabic sometime in the like
400 years before Gutenberg printed the
Bible and had no no impact by the Year
1400 all of the prints have disappeared
there is no surviving memory of their
ever having been printing and printing
is reintroduced into the Muslim world
very slowly in the 17th from the 17th
century onward and mostly in the 19th
century and it's a story that that gives
rise to questions of if you have a new
technology is there something
ineluctable about a technology that will
lead to its being - it's having an
impact - it's being used or are there
are there barriers that will cause
people to know about technology but not
to use it or to have a technology and
not recognize its purpose
or it's possible purpose the history of
technological developments in East Asia
that come to have extensions in the West
either in the Muslim world or in Europe
is a very well studied history usually
focusing on on gunpowder and and the
compass developments in the West having
an influence in China are talked about
less often and yet they are of some
importance particularly in the area of
of astronomy the central government of
China which what I say was you know the
government of China for for most of two
thousand years always had an astronomy
department a central agency that dealt
with with astronomy and with the
calendar it's it's sometimes functioned
with all the efficiency say of the US
Postal Service it's not known to be the
most imaginative Department but but the
whole notion that you would have a
government of an astronomy department
for two thousand years is somewhat
somewhat
hard to to grasp unless of course you're
a specialist on who cuvoodoo because
that will explain at all it's a you know
it's it's the kind of comparisons that
leave you puzzled as to not so much the
points of contact which people have
written so much about but at the
persistence of points of difference the
let me just take an obvious one a
chopsticks you have Westerners to go to
China
starting in the Mongol period
occasionally starting even before and
you can be sure that they all got there
and found the bleeding with chopsticks
and they all you know tried to eat with
chopsticks and they came back and they
talked about the marvels of China and
nobody brought any chopsticks back
chopsticks are great for eating but
nobody reports that they chopsticks and
and you sort of wonder why of course the
a Chinese point of view is a well metal
has a nasty taste so we shouldn't eat
with that of course you could say the
Europeans are eating with their fingers
and and licking their fingers afterwards
and so they like the taste but you sort
of wonder apply some things move and
some things don't
now next week when we get to talking
about pre-columbian America one of the
things that will eventually arise is
what's called the the Columbian Exchange
that was to say the exchange of products
and technologies and so on
across the Atlantic between Europe
and the Americas the story of exchange
and their little seemed sort of
straightforward you know we get turkeys
they get sheep that sort of thing
well the story of exchange between East
Asia and the actual Eurasian at cumin a
is is a much more mysterious one there
is a classic work by a scholar named
Berthold Lau fur called sino
ironic ax Lao fur was a work for the I
believe for the Field Museum in Chicago
Natural History Museum and what it is is
a list of all things known to have moved
one way or another
across the Silk Road and it gives the
Chinese names it gives the Latin names
and you see those things that move and
you look at the list and you think okay
what things didn't move why were some
things not not included or if something
that didn't move but that did move has
negligible effect so you know maybe
somebody brought chopsticks from China
and said you know my lord chopsticks you
can eat your your your roast duck with
the chopsticks he Isis stabbed in the
back or something you don't know we
don't know the details but you we know
for example that wine grapes and the
making of wine moves across the Silk
Road from the West to China and nobody
cares very much wine does not become a
big deal this doesn't mean the Chinese
don't drink you know go to a Chinese
banquet sometime
and see the variety of things that
you're offered but but wine wasn't as
interesting say as rice wine doesn't say
grape wine so
as
just thinking ahead on a for a personal
basis sometime at the beginning of
January the current plan holds the
remaining authors of the earth of his
peoples will get together in Boston and
will decide what do we want to see in a
sixth edition and one of the issues will
be do we need to hire an East Asian
historian to do competently what
professor bullet is doing in a
amateurish fashion and if so do we bring
in someone who will accept the structure
of things as we have it is that way as
we have had it for five comparative ly
successful editions or will or we will
we invite in an author and say start
over on East Asia do it your way we want
your view to be our new structure and if
so does that open up the whole question
of the structure of the book do we will
we even broach the topic of doing a
fundamental rethinking of how this book
approaches world history and I think
that how that discussion proceeds and
then whether we can sell the results to
the publishing company may major not be
very interesting but I can't imagine
what a new author would feel like coming
into an existing project as an East
Asian list I'm saying you know you can
start over and do it your way except it
has to fit with all the other chapters
because we're not going to read our
rewrite our chapters just for you and so
it'll be a puzzle but it's it's built
into the whole problem of
a world history becoming sort of
ossified prematurely that you get a
certain way of doing it it seems to work
other people imitate you or you imitate
other people publishers converge books
become more and more alike and will they
will the point come where we can do a
start over and if you're going to do is
start over clearly you need new people
to suggest how to do it and also younger
people as someone who turned 70 last
week I am very conscious of not being
the youngest person on the planet and so
this will whether this is the last time
I teach this course or not I teach it
again in a few years who knows I may be
teaching a very different look so I'll
stop here and we'll go to the new world
next time